murray was last seen at the emerald
suites in the area of twain in paradise
search crews were out there
again today searching for any potential
clues joe mohler also out there live
right now joining us with the very
latest on this investigation
joe brian earlier today
a lot of people were coming by this
parking lot here trying to help get
information they're picking up flyers
just like this they could pass them out
to the community
now just a short time ago metro released
a video regarding this case they say
they're still looking for
information they're working day and
night trying to get whatever they can
and this is the complex next door to
this parking lot where
omari was last known to be and metro
says they went door to door seeking
information here
for days now a non-profit has been
coming to this area to set up a search
party and a booth to get information out
amari was last seen wednesday his mom
says her boyfriend was watching him
the boyfriend told me someone from the
father's side picked up omaree but he
didn't say who
that family says that is not true people
have been coming throughout the day
here we met tiana allen who stopped by
to pick up a sack of flyers
this has my attention because
i know this neighborhood we're by the
strip
there's cameras all throughout here okay
the story didn't make sense
i'm a mother i can never just leave my
kid
amari's aunt from california came to
help as well she says they have not
talked with the child's mom
and they have not seen her yolanda
everett says they are getting desperate
for
any sort of tip we couldn't do anything
in california
we had to be here and talk to people so
they see that he does have family
there's people that really care about
him and want him to come home
amari's father lives in reno and was
reportedly there when he went missing he
was
he has since been in las vegas helping
with his search now back out here live
some people have been wondering why
there has been no amber alert related to
this case and that is because there is
no
suspect description or vehicle involved
that they know of so that is why there
has been no amber alert now the father's
side of the family
yolanda you just heard there they are
putting out 30 thousand dollars for any
information leading to
omari's whereabouts reporting live here
near twain and paradise joe moore 8 news
now